This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you're on a highway stuck in bumper to bumper traffic, all cities start to feel the same. It's easy to forget that you're in a particular place on the Earth's surface, a coast or a bay or a desert or a plane. Mexico City is one of the biggest, busiest, trafficiest cities in the world, but it's also a highland valley, over 7,000 feet in the air, surrounded on all sides by volcanoes. Sometimes these volcanoes spit up a little fire and smoke to remind people of the volatile
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。当你堵在高速公路的车流中时，所有的城市感觉都一样。你很容易忘记自己正处于地球表面的某个特定位置——海岸、海湾、沙漠或平原。墨西哥城是世界上最大、最繁忙、交通最拥堵的城市之一，但它同时也是一个海拔7000多英尺的高原山谷，四周环绕着火山。有时，这些火山会喷出少许火光和烟雾，提醒人们周围那不稳定的
geology all around them. But about a millennium and a half ago, a volcano called Sheetlay, fully erupted. Molten lava poured into the valley, destroying an indigenous city and covering 30 square miles in a bed of volcanic stone. Today, most of this lava field has been paved over, with roads and buildings and parking lots devoured by the largest city in North America, Mexico City. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. But in the midst of all this urban sprawl, there's one spot where you can still get a good look at that old volcanic rock.
地质环境。但大约一千五百年前，一座名为“希特莱”（Xitle）的火山彻底爆发了。熔岩涌入山谷，摧毁了一座原住民城市，并将30平方英里的土地覆盖在火山岩层之下。如今，这片熔岩区的大部分已被铺平，道路、建筑和停车场被北美最大的城市——墨西哥城所吞噬。那是制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。但在这一切城市扩张之中，仍有一个地方可以让你一睹那些古老的火山岩。
So you can see now in 2019 rocks that are exactly the same as 1,600 years ago. This is Pedro Camarena, he's a landscape architect and we're in the Pedro Gal they sign on hell ecological reserve. It's a small park in South Mexico city that contains the last remnants of the old lava field. Looking down at the ground, you can see swirls and folds in the rock.
所以你现在在2019年看到的岩石，和1600年前的一模一样。这是佩德罗·卡马雷纳，他是一位景观设计师，我们现在位于佩德雷加尔（Pedregal）生态保护区。这是墨西哥城南部的一个小公园，保留了古老熔岩区的最后遗迹。低头看地面，你可以看到岩石上的漩涡和褶皱。
How the lava was moving as it cooled all those centuries ago. Yeah, you can see that, that ripple. Yeah, oh yeah, look at that. In Spanish or Cordones. In English, El Pijegal means the rocky place. And it's a fitting name. The ground here is made of purplish black stone and covered in bright green light in. Dry brown grasses are growing up through the cracks, but Pedro says that when the seasonal rains come,
那是几个世纪前熔岩冷却时留下的痕迹。是的，你可以看到那个涟漪。没错，看那个。在西班牙语中叫“Cordones”。在英语里，“El Pedregal”意为“多石之地”。这个名字很贴切。这里的地面由紫黑色的石头构成，覆盖着亮绿色的地衣。干枯的棕色草丛从裂缝中长出，但佩德罗说，当季节性降雨来临时，
this whole landscape will transform. In rainy season, it turns green and a lot of corals from orange, red, yellow, purple, blue, a lot of wild flowers. So this is beautiful. Pedro, Camarena, is probably the Pedro Gauls number one fan. Here in the Pedral, there are 300 of different species of plants. There are two or three endemic species.
整个景观都会发生变化。雨季时，这里会变绿，还有许多橙色、红色、黄色、紫色、蓝色的珊瑚状花朵，以及许多野花。所以这里非常美。佩德罗·卡马雷纳大概是佩德雷加尔的头号粉丝。在佩德雷加尔，有300种不同的植物，其中有两三种是特有物种。
Only here in this place, you can find that one is an orchid, and the other one is a cactus. There's also a tiny little frog that only appears in the rainy season, but by night. But some nights you can stay here in this place and listen to frog the little frog. Very very is magical and many people, even me, are very grace about this landscape. Pedro is not the first architect to fall in love with the betrugal. Back in the 1940s, this love of field became the muse of the great Mexican modernist Luis Baragon. Baragon is a giant of Mexican architecture. He's famous for designing simple cubic houses painted with bold, bright colors, yellows and reds and fuchsias.
只有在这里才能找到，一种是兰花，另一种是仙人掌。还有一种只有在雨季夜晚才会出现的小青蛙。但有些夜晚，你可以待在这里，听听那只小青蛙的叫声。非常、非常神奇，许多人，甚至包括我，都对这片景观感到非常敬畏。佩德罗并不是第一位爱上佩德雷加尔的建筑师。早在20世纪40年代，这片熔岩区就成为了伟大的墨西哥现代主义者路易斯·巴拉干的灵感缪斯。巴拉干是墨西哥建筑界的巨人。他以设计简单的立方体房屋而闻名，这些房屋涂有大胆、明亮的颜色，如黄色、红色和紫红色。
His vivid, single-color walls are like the perfect Instagram background. And Baragon designed some of his most interesting houses among the rocks of the Patriot Gal. But in attempting to build harmoniously with this volcanic landscape, he may have accidentally led to its demise and contributed to an ecological crisis that threatens the future of the entire city. Luis Baragon moved to Mexico City from Guadalajara in the late 1930s. The city was in the middle of a building boom and amidst all that construction and growth, the Pedro Gal about 10 miles south of the city center was one of the few places that
他那生动、单色的墙壁就像完美的Instagram背景。巴拉干在佩德雷加尔的岩石间设计了一些他最有趣的房子。但为了与这片火山景观和谐共处，他可能无意中导致了它的消亡，并加剧了一场威胁整个城市未来的生态危机。路易斯·巴拉干在20世纪30年代末从瓜达拉哈拉搬到了墨西哥城。当时城市正处于建筑热潮中，在所有的建设和增长中，位于市中心以南约10英里的佩德雷加尔是少数几个
remained completely undeveloped. Baragon used to explore the lava field on weekend hikes with his artist friends. Baragon, like a lot of other artistically-minded people, including Diego Rivera, became enamored of this place. This is Keith Egnor. He is an architectural historian at the University of Oregon, who wrote a book about Luis Baragon. He says that Baragon fell in love with the Pedro Gal for its physical beauty, but also because the landscape felt distinctly Mexican. It was a place that the Spanish had never tamed, had never colonized. It was a place with, you know, views of the
完全未被开发的地方之一。巴拉干过去常在周末与艺术家朋友们一起徒步探索这片熔岩区。像迭戈·里维拉等许多具有艺术头脑的人一样，巴拉干也迷上了这个地方。这是基思·埃格诺。他是俄勒冈大学的建筑历史学家，曾写过一本关于路易斯·巴拉干的书。他说，巴拉干爱上佩德雷加尔不仅是因为它的自然美，还因为这片景观具有独特的墨西哥特色。这是一个从未被西班牙人驯服、从未被殖民过的地方。这是一个可以俯瞰
volcanoes that were so central to a lot of, you know, Mexican mythology and Mexican history. And Baragon decided to build there. He came up with the plan of building houses, modern houses, and gardens on this again very distinct volcanic site. He called the project Los Hardines de la Péderigal. For years this uneven rocky landscape deterred would be developers, but Beragon saw the lava as an asset. And rather than breaking up the lava and
火山的地方，而火山在许多墨西哥神话和历史中都占据核心地位。于是巴拉干决定在那里建造。他提出了在这个非常独特的火山遗址上建造现代住宅和花园的计划。他将该项目命名为“佩德雷加尔花园”（Los Jardines del Pedregal）。多年来，这种崎岖不平的岩石景观让开发商望而却步，但巴拉干却将熔岩视为一种资产。他没有打碎熔岩，
carting it away and trying to level off the ground as other people might have done, Baragon developed this idea to keep much of the lava and the native vegetation in place. This idea was inspired by architects like Frank Lloyd Wright, who believed that the design of a building should reflect the landscape on which it was built. Just as Wright designed his famous falling waterhouse around the spectacular waterfall in Pennsylvania, Beragon wanted to design homes inspired by this majestic lava field. And so he decided that all houses in the Patrick Hall should be simple and modern and made from basic local materials. Streets should follow the natural contours of the rock,
也没有将其运走或试图平整地面，而是构思出一种保留大部分熔岩和原生植被的理念。这一想法受到了弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特等建筑师的启发，他们认为建筑的设计应反映其所处的景观。正如赖特围绕宾夕法尼亚州壮观的瀑布设计了他著名的“流水别墅”一样，巴拉干也想设计出受这片雄伟熔岩区启发的住宅。因此，他决定佩德雷加尔的所有房屋都应简洁、现代，并使用基本的当地材料。街道应遵循岩石的自然轮廓，
and lots should be kept really large, as much as 30,000 square feet. And that houses only take up a relatively small percentage of those lots, the rest to be left to gardens. Baragon was obsessed with gardens. This could be apocryphal, but supposedly he used to say, I don't build houses with gardens, I build gardens with houses. And he wanted the gardens of the Pagegal to be oaths to this unique volcanic landscape.
地块应保持非常大，甚至达到30,000平方英尺。房屋仅占这些地块中相对较小的比例，其余部分留作花园。巴拉干对花园有着执念。这可能未经证实，但据说他常说：“我不建造带花园的房子，我建造带房子的花园。”他希望佩德雷加尔的花园能成为对这片独特火山景观的颂歌。
The substantial portion of the original lava should be left on site, and only small patches of lawn might be used, distinct native trees and shrubs were to be left in place and cultivated. Beragon began working in the Pedrogol in the late 1940s. His first houses were carefully nestled among the rocks and integrated seamlessly with the volcanic landscape. The gardens featured little stairways cut into the stone that allowed you to move through the space. There's even a spot in one of the houses where a huge piece of lava comes through the wall. And if all this sounds pretty expensive, well, it was. Barragans' goal was to convince wealthy professionals to escape the crowded noisy city center in favor of the fresh air and beautiful scenery of the lava field. And he hired a photographer named Armando Salas Portugal to really capture the vibe.
大部分原始熔岩应留在现场，仅使用小块草坪，独特的原生树木和灌木应保留并加以培育。巴拉干于20世纪40年代末开始在佩德雷加尔工作。他最初的房屋小心翼翼地坐落在岩石之间，与火山景观无缝融合。花园里有切入石头的阶梯，让你可以在空间中穿行。其中一栋房子里甚至有一块巨大的熔岩穿墙而过。如果这一切听起来很昂贵，嗯，确实如此。巴拉干的目标是说服富有的专业人士逃离拥挤嘈杂的市中心，转而享受熔岩区清新的空气和美丽的风景。他聘请了一位名叫阿曼多·萨拉斯·葡萄牙的摄影师来捕捉这种氛围。
Salas Portugal's beautiful photos of well-to-do Mexican families wandering through the rock gardens helped sell Paragon's lava lifestyle to the Mexico City Elite. You can live in the paradise, very exotic place with a lot of lava. Here's Pedro Camarena again. Nobody's around you. You came with your Cadillac 57 or your Buick 59. And you look like a curry grant or something like that. So many people make succeed.
萨拉斯·葡萄牙拍摄的那些富裕的墨西哥家庭在岩石花园中漫步的美丽照片，帮助巴拉干将他的“熔岩生活方式”推销给了墨西哥城的精英阶层。你可以生活在天堂里，一个有很多熔岩的异国情调的地方。这是佩德罗·卡马雷纳。周围没有人。你开着你的57年款凯迪拉克或59年款别克。你看上去就像加里·格兰特之类的人。所以很多人成功了。
Yes, we want to live like that way, no? I mean, it sounds pretty cool to me. Right? You live in this rugged wilderness, just a short drive from your downtown office job like a sophisticated cowboy. Yeah, but new cow is with a carry like instead of a horse. If I have money at that time,
是的，我们想那样生活，不是吗？我的意思是，这对我来说听起来很酷。对吧？你住在这种崎岖的荒野中，距离你的市中心办公室工作只有很短的车程，就像一个老练的牛仔。是的，但那是开着凯迪拉克的牛仔，而不是骑马。如果我当时有钱，
I for sure bought a house in the Pentagon, of course. If you aren't able to visit Metzgosody, Armando Salas Portugas' photographs are probably the best way to experience Barragán's architecture and his vision of harmony between building and landscape. But the truth is, that vision never really came to pass in the real world. In the early 1950s, Barragán got bought out of the project. And soon all his utopian ideas about how the landscape should be developed went out the window. The city was growing at a breakneck pace, and here was this source of cheap land. And so you can see in these aerial
我肯定会在佩德雷加尔买一栋房子。当然，如果你无法访问墨西哥城，阿曼多·萨拉斯·葡萄牙的照片可能是体验巴拉干的建筑和他对建筑与景观和谐愿景的最佳方式。但事实是，那个愿景在现实世界中从未真正实现。20世纪50年代初，巴拉干被挤出了该项目。很快，他关于景观应如何开发的所有乌托邦思想都化为泡影。城市正以惊人的速度扩张，而这里成了廉价土地的来源。所以你可以从这些航拍
photographs, El Pedragal in 1950, there's a few houses and roads there by 1959, the place is densely packed with houses and very much built up. The houses got bigger and the gardens got smaller. And newcomers to the area didn't seem to share Baragon's reverence for the lava. They covered up the rocks with dry waves and lawns and gardens full of non-native plants. And it's easy to think about this story as a kind of eco-architectural paradise lost.
照片中看到，1950年的佩德雷加尔只有几栋房子和道路，到了1959年，这里已经密密麻麻地盖满了房子，建筑林立。房子变大了，花园变小了。而新来的人似乎并不像巴拉干那样敬畏熔岩。他们用干草坪和种满非原生植物的花园覆盖了岩石。人们很容易将这个故事视为一种生态建筑天堂的失落。
In part, because of the way people talk about Louis Baragon. He's kind of come down to us in the architectural hegeography and the literature as this mystic monk sort of remote from modern life in many ways. And there's certainly truth in that. But at the same time, he was also a very successful businessman, even a rather repacious real estate developer. Ignor says that Baragon knew what he was doing. That paradise was always very ephemeral.
部分原因是人们谈论路易斯·巴拉干的方式。在建筑传记和文献中，他被塑造成一种神秘的僧侣形象，在许多方面远离现代生活。这当然有其真实的一面。但与此同时，他也是一位非常成功的商人，甚至是一位相当贪婪的房地产开发商。埃格诺说，巴拉干很清楚自己在做什么。那个天堂一直是非常短暂的。
It was never really meant to last. And again, I don't think Baragon really expected it to last, and again I don't think Baragon really expected it to last. Between the 50s and the 80s, nearly the entire lava field was developed. Today about a half million people live on top of the petrogon. There are fancy neighborhoods and poor ones, but aside from the little preserve where our story began, the lava rock is basically gone. And it would be fair to put that all on the West Beragon. But the irony is, as much as he genuinely loved that lava landscape,
它注定不会长久。再说一次，我不认为巴拉干真的指望它能长久，再说一次，我不认为巴拉干真的指望它能长久。从50年代到80年代，几乎整个熔岩区都被开发了。今天，大约有五十万人居住在佩德雷加尔之上。这里有高档社区，也有贫困社区，但除了我们故事开始的那个小保护区外，熔岩基本上已经消失了。把这一切都归咎于巴拉干或许有失公允。但讽刺的是，尽管他真心热爱那片熔岩景观，
in a way he facilitated its demise. That project of beautiful houses in Jarines del Pedregal, they trigger the urbanization in South Mexico City. And then, it starts to develop urban development, and that's the fat of error. Pedro Camarena thinks that developing El Pedro Ga was a fatal error, not just because the rocks look pretty, or were home to some cool plants and animals. He says that covering up this unique geology contributed to a deeper problem, an ecological crisis that's playing out in Mexico City today. A crisis rooted in the city's extremely complicated relationship with water.
在某种程度上，他却促成了它的消亡。那个在佩德雷加尔花园建造美丽房屋的项目，触发了墨西哥城南部的城市化。然后，城市开发开始了，那是致命的错误。佩德罗·卡马雷纳认为开发佩德雷加尔是一个致命的错误，不仅仅是因为岩石看起来很漂亮，或者它们是一些酷炫动植物的家园。他说，覆盖这种独特的地质结构导致了一个更深层次的问题，一场正在墨西哥城上演的生态危机。这场危机植根于该市与水之间极其复杂的关系。
Yeah, for Mexico City, the trouble with water is quite complex and it all starts in the moment that someone decided to build a city upon a lake. This is Loreta Castro Rivera. I'm Loreta Castro Rivera, I'm an architect and an urban designer and I do design, design for the city and design with water. Castro Vergara says that the Valley of Mexico is actually more of a basin. It's a closed basin. It's like a bowl, which has no natural water exits.
是的，对于墨西哥城来说，水的问题相当复杂，这一切都始于有人决定在湖泊之上建立城市的那一刻。这是洛雷塔·卡斯特罗·里维拉。我是洛雷塔·卡斯特罗·里维拉，我是一名建筑师和城市设计师，我为城市做设计，也与水共设计。卡斯特罗·里维拉说，墨西哥谷实际上更像是一个盆地。这是一个封闭的盆地。它就像一个碗，没有天然的出水口。
So when it rains, all the runoff concentrates in the lower areas of the basin, and this bowl starts filling up. For centuries, the basin was filled with a series of rainwater lakes. The Aztecs built their capital, Tenochtitlan, on an island in the middle of one of those lakes. They built causeways and canals and floating gardens. It was like the Venice of Mesoamerica. But when Spanish conquistadors sac Tenochtitlan, they rebuilt the city as if it was just
所以当雨季来临时，所有的径流都集中在盆地的低洼地区，这个碗就开始积水了。几个世纪以来，盆地里充满了雨水湖。阿兹特克人在其中一个湖的中心岛上建立了他们的首都特诺奇蒂特兰。他们建造了堤道、运河和浮动花园。它就像美索不达米亚的威尼斯。但当西班牙征服者洗劫特诺奇蒂特兰时，他们重建了这座城市，就好像它只是
any old city in Spain, with a centralized grid. So that's when real trouble starts happening. Nearly every year when the seasonal rains came, the colonial city would flood. And we're talking serious flooding. After the flood of 1629, Mexico City was under water for four years. And in that moment, the government, the vice-roy decided to open the first canal that would start draining the lake system. Over the course of the next several centuries, Mexico City built an elaborate system of tunnels designed to evacuate rainwater out of the basin and prevent flooding. Little by little, the city drained the lakes
西班牙的任何一座旧城市一样，采用了中心化的网格布局。所以真正的麻烦从那时就开始了。几乎每年季节性降雨来临时，殖民城市都会被淹。我们说的是严重的洪水。1629年大洪水后，墨西哥城被淹了四年。就在那一刻，政府，即总督，决定开凿第一条运河，开始排干湖泊系统。在接下来的几个世纪里，墨西哥城建造了一套复杂的隧道系统，旨在将雨水排出盆地，防止洪水。城市一点一点地排干了湖泊，
and expanded out over the dry lake bed. But Mexico City also suffers from a second water problem, one that seems almost paradoxical. Even as it gets inundated every year with rains and floods, the city is running out of water. In the middle of the 20th century, Mexico City's population exploded, and all of those people needed to drink.
并扩展到了干涸的湖床上。但墨西哥城还面临着第二个水问题，一个看起来几乎自相矛盾的问题。尽管每年都被雨水和洪水淹没，但这座城市却面临缺水。20世纪中叶，墨西哥城人口爆炸，所有这些人需要饮水。
The seasonal rain could have provided a reliable source of fresh water, but Mexico City had just built a massive system of infrastructure designed specifically to get rid of it. And now, with the 23 million inhabitants in the city, there is not enough drinking water to satisfy the necessities of all this enormous population. Today, many neighborhoods in Mexico City don't have reliable running water.
季节性降雨本可以提供可靠的淡水来源，但墨西哥城刚刚建造了一套专门用于排走雨水的大型基础设施系统。现在，随着城市拥有2300万居民，没有足够的饮用水来满足如此庞大人口的需求。今天，墨西哥城的许多社区没有可靠的自来水。
And then, when the rainy season comes, those same neighborhoods get far too much water, all at once. So we live in these paradoxes of urban floods and water scarcity. To solve this scarcity issue, the city took two approaches. They piped water in from far away, and they pumped it up from the aquifer blow ground. Which in turn created a third problem. In the early 20s of last century, some engineers saw that the city was sinking. This is Manuel Peralo Cohen, he's director of the Institute for Social Research
然后，当雨季来临时，同样的社区又会同时遭遇过多的水。所以我们生活在城市洪水和水资源短缺的悖论中。为了解决短缺问题，城市采取了两种方法。他们从远方引水，并从地下含水层抽取。这反过来又造成了第三个问题。上世纪20年代初，一些工程师发现城市正在下沉。这是曼努埃尔·佩拉洛·科恩，他是墨西哥国立自治大学社会研究所的所长。
at the National Autonomous University of Mexico. Some buildings sank five centimeters per year, and some of them thin. The reason was pretty straightforward. As more and more people took more and more water out of the aquifer every year, the muddy lakebed soil began to crack and crumble like a stale cookie. And that's why the city began to sink.
有些建筑物每年下沉五厘米，有些则更严重。原因很简单。随着越来越多的人每年从含水层抽取越来越多的水，泥泞的湖床土壤开始像陈旧的饼干一样开裂和崩塌。这就是城市开始下沉的原因。
Today, Mexico City is pumping water out of the aquifer twice as fast as it can replenish, and the city has sunk about 30 feet over the past century. If you walk around Mexico City today, you can see this in the landscape. Crooked skylines, sinkholes and places where the ground is completely uneven. Mexico City is flooded, thirsty, and sinking. And climate change is only going to make all of it more extreme. It's an impossibly complicated problem with no easy solution. But with impossibly complicated problem with no easy solution.
今天，墨西哥城抽取含水层水的速度是其补给速度的两倍，过去一个世纪里，城市已经下沉了约30英尺。如果你今天在墨西哥城走动，你可以在景观中看到这一点。歪斜的天际线、天坑以及地面完全不平整的地方。墨西哥城既被淹没，又干渴，还在下沉。而气候变化只会让这一切变得更加极端。这是一个极其复杂、没有简单解决方案的问题。但面对极其复杂、没有简单解决方案的问题，
But with impossibly complicated problems, you have to start somewhere. And Pedro Camarena thinks that one place worth considering is the lava fields of El Pedro Gal. So let's take a look at what is the Pedro Gal I'm going to show you. Yeah, yeah. I'm going to show you why these water run very, very easy in this lava field. Pedro is one of several architects who have started thinking about ways the city could recharge its groundwater aquifer. In most places, recharge just isn't possible. The ground beneath the old lake is made of clay that retains water on the surface and prevents it from flowing underground.
你必须从某个地方开始。佩德罗·卡马雷纳认为，佩德雷加尔的熔岩区是一个值得考虑的地方。所以让我们看看什么是佩德雷加尔，我带你去看看。是的，是的。我会告诉你为什么这些水在熔岩区流得非常、非常容易。佩德罗是几位开始思考城市如何补充地下含水层的建筑师之一。在大多数地方，补给根本是不可能的。旧湖底下的地面是由粘土构成的，它将水保留在地表，阻止其流入地下。
But in a few places around the edges of the old lake, the landscape is rocky and permeable. And you think it'll pay the regal is probably the best place. The best place, of course, because because lava fields are the most permeable geology on earth. Back in the Pagogal ecological reserve, Kamarena bends down and points to a piece of lava rock. Look, there's a lot of holes, there's a lot of pores. Very porous stone, thank you. It looks like one of those pumice stones that people use in the shower to scrape dead skin off their feet. Yeah, more or less.
但在旧湖边缘的少数地方，景观是岩石状且可渗透的。你认为佩德雷加尔可能是最好的地方。当然是最好的地方，因为熔岩区是地球上渗透性最强的地质结构。回到佩德雷加尔生态保护区，卡马雷纳弯下腰，指着一块熔岩。看，有很多洞，有很多孔。非常多孔的石头，谢谢。它看起来就像人们在淋浴时用来刮掉脚上死皮的浮石。是的，差不多。
Pagro says that for years when rain fell on the Pedro Gal, the water would easily trickle down through this porous stone into the aquifer below ground. Can you think you've came a big, big storm? Do you think you can find a lagoon here? Of course not. But the same cannot be said for most places on the old lava field. Because apart from this ecological
佩德罗说，多年来，当雨水落在佩德雷加尔时，水会很容易地通过这些多孔的石头渗入地下的含水层。你认为如果来了一场大暴雨，你能在那里找到一个泻湖吗？当然不能。但对于旧熔岩区的大多数地方来说，情况并非如此。因为除了这个生态
reserve, nearly all of the porous volcanic rock is gone, covered up by layers of impermeable concrete. And so, when the rains come, the water just runs off the pavement into the sewer system. But Pedro Comorano wants to change that. The only thing we have to do is to depave the rocky fields in the south. We have 80 square kilometers of big lava field. Obviously it's very, very urbanized now, but we can depave. Do you understand what I mean?
保护区外，几乎所有多孔的火山岩都消失了，被一层层不透水的混凝土覆盖。因此，当雨季来临时，水只是从路面流进下水道系统。但佩德罗·卡马雷纳想改变这一点。我们唯一要做的就是拆除南部的岩石区路面。我们有80平方公里的巨大熔岩区。显然现在它已经非常、非常城市化了，但我们可以拆除路面。你明白我的意思吗？
What he means is get rid of all the unnecessary pavement that's plugging up all those volcanic pores Camarena wants to depave parking lots and medians and create volcanic infiltration zones where rain water could flow back to the aquifer You have to be cautious. You can't create an infiltration zone next to a toxic waste dump or you could contaminate the whole water supply But Pedro wants to carefully peel back the city's concrete skin. To expose the lava and try to restore the lava field. Because the old lava field is still there beneath all the asphalt. If you go to Los Hardines del Péthedigal today, upscale neighborhood that Luis Barragón started back in the 40s, you can catch a glimpse of this buried landscape, little pieces
他的意思是摆脱所有堵塞那些火山孔隙的不必要路面。卡马雷纳想拆除停车场和隔离带，建立火山渗透区，让雨水可以流回含水层。你必须谨慎。你不能在有毒废物堆旁边建立渗透区，否则你可能会污染整个供水系统。但佩德罗想小心地剥开城市的混凝土外壳，露出熔岩，并试图恢复熔岩区。因为旧的熔岩区仍然存在于所有沥青之下。如果你今天去路易斯·巴拉干在40年代开始开发的佩德雷加尔花园，你可以瞥见这片被掩埋的景观，小块的
of lava poking through the grass and the concrete. For the most part, though, it looks like other affluent neighborhoods in Mexico City. A lot of lawns with sprinklers. So they prefer to put a lot of grass and let me tell you, they spend, now days, they spend a lot of money in irrigation. But Pedro wants to shift how people in Mexico City think about gardening. A while back, he was asked to design a garden to go with a public art sculpture that was built in the Patriot Golf 40 years earlier. And instead of planting a bunch of flowers and shrubs, he just started digging. So I create that garden only by excavating digging.
熔岩从草地和混凝土中探出头来。不过，在很大程度上，它看起来和其他墨西哥城的富裕社区一样。有很多带喷灌系统的草坪。所以他们更喜欢种很多草，我得告诉你，他们现在花很多钱在灌溉上。但佩德罗想改变墨西哥城人们对园艺的看法。前段时间，有人请他设计一个花园，以配合40年前在佩德雷加尔建造的一座公共艺术雕塑。他没有种一堆花草灌木，而是直接开始挖掘。所以我通过挖掘来创造那个花园。
Gardening by subtraction. Pedro calls this landscape archeology. We start with three guys, old guys, digging like archeological site. They start to remove plants then soil and then then starts to appear the lava field beautiful. It's a lot more work than planning tulips but Pedro says that people in the Pagregol can do landscape archaeology on their own property, uncover the lava and build baragon style dry rock gardens
通过减法进行园艺。佩德罗称之为景观考古学。我们从三个人开始，老家伙们，像考古现场一样挖掘。他们开始移除植物，然后是土壤，然后熔岩区开始显现，非常美。这比种郁金香要费力得多，但佩德罗说，佩德雷加尔的人们可以在自己的房产上进行景观考古，揭开熔岩，建造巴拉干风格的干石花园，
that don't require any irrigation. But it's a tough sell. People want gardens that look like Versailles. Yes, we are very dependent, emotionally dependent, in Europe. We still design gardens like in France. I mean, it's ridiculous. Because we don't have the landscape of France, we don't have the weather, we don't have the soil,
不需要任何灌溉。但这很难推销。人们想要看起来像凡尔赛宫的花园。是的，我们在情感上非常依赖欧洲。我们仍然像在法国那样设计花园。我的意思是，这很荒谬。因为我们没有法国的景观，我们没有那样的天气，我们没有那样的土壤，
this means very different. But Pedro told me that there is one house in Los Hardinis del Péritigal, where you can still see a true Mexican lava rock garden. It's actually one of the first houses built in the area, designed by Baragon himself, back in the 40s. The property underwent a lot of changes in the decades since. But a few years ago, a new owner, a man named Cesars Avantes, decided to restore the house
这意味着非常不同。但佩德罗告诉我，在佩德雷加尔花园里还有一栋房子，你仍然可以看到一个真正的墨西哥熔岩石花园。它实际上是该地区建造的第一批房屋之一，由巴拉干本人在40年代设计。自那以后的几十年里，该房产经历了很多变化。但几年前，一位新主人，一个名叫塞萨尔·塞万提斯的人，决定修复这栋房子，
to the way he had looked in Baragon's day, and Pedro convinced him to uncover the original lava rock. And he did it. And now everybody told me, Pedro, you have to see, you have to go to Cesar House to see what's happened there. Have you seen it? No, I asked him and he said, come, whatever, whenever you want, but I don't have time. I, on the other hand, have plenty of time.
恢复到巴拉干时代的模样，佩德罗说服他揭开了原始的熔岩。他做到了。现在每个人都告诉我，佩德罗，你必须去看看，你必须去塞萨尔的房子看看那里发生了什么。你看到了吗？不，我问他，他说，来吧，无论什么时候，但我没时间。另一方面，我有的是时间。
I am Cesar Cervantes and we are at Casa Pedra. Cesar grew up in this neighborhood, and says that back then no one really wanted to see visible lava in their garden. And I remember even my father covering or getting rid of visible lava, favoring grass or assuming bulls too late. When Cesar bought this house, the previous owners had covered up the original baragon rock garden with an astroturf pudding green.
我是塞萨尔·塞万提斯，我们在佩德雷加尔之家。塞萨尔在这个社区长大，他说那时没有人真的想在花园里看到裸露的熔岩。我记得连我父亲都把裸露的熔岩覆盖掉或清理掉，偏爱草坪或……太晚了。当塞萨尔买下这栋房子时，前任主人已经用人造草皮果岭覆盖了巴拉干最初的岩石花园。
But Cesar and his team started doing a little landscape archaeology. We start removing and removing layers, layers of grass, baked grass, and cement. And slowly the original lava field began to re-emerge. As he was coming back to its original condition, he was really, really, breathtaking. And it really is. Cesar kindly let me take a tour of his home with a guide named Mariana Esqueda. Before we got to the garden, Mariana showed me the house. The walls are thick and heavy and painted this delightful shade of pink. As she opened the door, I was yammering on about something or other, and the house kind of took my breath away.
但塞萨尔和他的团队开始进行一点景观考古。我们开始移除、移除一层又一层，草皮、枯草和水泥。慢慢地，原始的熔岩区开始重新显现。当它恢复到原始状态时，真的、真的很令人惊叹。确实如此。塞萨尔好心地让我和一位名叫玛丽安娜·埃斯奎达的导游一起参观了他的家。在我们到达花园之前，玛丽安娜带我参观了房子。墙壁厚重，漆成这种令人愉悦的粉红色。当她打开门时，我还在喋喋不休地说着什么，房子让我屏住了呼吸。
The garden of Pichagall, like what was he trying? Wow. It just, it sounds so quiet. Yes, I know. It's one characteristic on Baragon. Not you can feel the silence, the tranquility. Yeah, it feels almost like a church. Yes. After showing me around the house, Mariana led me back to the garden.
佩德雷加尔的花园，他到底在尝试什么？哇。它听起来太安静了。是的，我知道。这是巴拉干的一个特征。你可以感受到宁静，那种安宁。是的，感觉几乎像一座教堂。是的。带我参观完房子后，玛丽安娜带我回到了花园。
We scrambled down a rocky path, and then suddenly we're surrounded on all sides by porous black lava. It was unlike any garden I've ever been in. More like a nature preserve filled with Mexican plants and animals. Like succulents, like cactools. I mean, look, there's a... Yeah.
我们爬下一条岩石小径，突然我们四面八方都被多孔的黑色熔岩包围了。这和我去过的任何花园都不一样。更像是一个充满墨西哥动植物的自然保护区。比如多肉植物，比如仙人掌。我的意思是，看，那里有一个……是的。
There's like lizards right there. There's half manilissars everywhere. Ha, ha. It feels... Yeah, it feels... wild. It's really beautiful. Sayzar says that when his neighbors first saw the rock, it was clear that they didn't even know they'd lived on top of a lava field. Where did you bring this lava from or how did it appear here?
那里到处都是蜥蜴。到处都是蜥蜴。哈哈。感觉……是的，感觉……很野性。真的很美。塞萨尔说，当他的邻居第一次看到这些岩石时，很明显他们甚至不知道自己住在熔岩区之上。你从哪里弄来的这些熔岩，或者它是怎么出现在这里的？
But Pedro Camarena hopes that if more people see these rocks, maybe they'll follow suit and dig up the lava in their own backyards. Rock gardens in rich neighborhoods are not going to solve the water crisis, not even close. But every bit of lava that gets uncovered is a tiny step in the right direction towards rebalancing the city's relationship with its groundwater. A huge thank you this week to the fantastic environmental reporter Zoe Schleiner, her great piece in courts about Mexico City's water problems clued us into Pedro Camarena and his work. Zoe has written a lot of great stories about water and climate change and other environmental issues.
但佩德罗·卡马雷纳希望，如果更多人看到这些岩石，也许他们会效仿，挖掘自家后院的熔岩。富人区的岩石花园并不能解决水危机，甚至差得远。但每一块被揭开的熔岩都是朝着重新平衡城市与地下水关系迈出的一小步。本周非常感谢出色的环境记者佐伊·施莱纳，她在《石英》杂志上关于墨西哥城水问题的精彩报道让我们了解了佩德罗·卡马雷纳和他的工作。佐伊写过许多关于水、气候变化和其他环境问题的精彩报道。
You can find links to more for work on our website at 99pi.org. After the break, we'll talk about the bigger picture and what architects and designers are trying to do to solve Mexico City's water crisis. So I'm back with Emmett in the studio and we want to take a second to zoom out and talk a little bit about the bigger picture when it comes to the Mexico City water crisis. Yeah, and if you talk to Loreta Castro-Vigara, who is one of the architects that we heard from in the story, she'll tell you that it's a question of design. Design is really a key element in this situation.
你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上找到更多关于她作品的链接。休息之后，我们将讨论更大的图景，以及建筑师和设计师正在尝试做些什么来解决墨西哥城的水危机。所以我回到了演播室和埃米特在一起，我们想花点时间缩小视角，谈谈墨西哥城水危机的大局。是的，如果你和洛雷塔·卡斯特罗·里维拉交谈，她是我们在故事中听到的建筑师之一，她会告诉你这是一个设计问题。设计确实是这种情况下的关键要素。
For us, it's the language we speak with water. Oh, I like speaking in the language of design. Yeah, I know. She sounds like a 99 PI disciple. Dream guest. You know, Loretta says that there's really no, there's no silver bullet design solution for Mexico City's problems.
对我们来说，这是我们与水交流的语言。哦，我喜欢用设计的语言交流。是的，我知道。她听起来像个《99%隐形》的信徒。梦想嘉宾。你知道，洛雷塔说，对于墨西哥城的问题，真的没有所谓的“银弹”设计方案。
But what she kept coming back to with me was that fundamentally the city has to change its relationship to rain. So what do you mean by that? Well, you know, Mexico City is different than a lot of other cities that are facing water shortages around the world and that they do get rain. It rains, it rains, that you know, Cape Town,
但她一直向我强调的是，从根本上讲，这座城市必须改变与雨水的关系。那么你是什么意思呢？嗯，你知道，墨西哥城与世界上许多面临水资源短缺的城市不同，因为他们确实有雨。下雨，下雨，你知道，开普敦，
South Africa would love to have as much rain as Mexico City does. But because of this history with flooding, which we heard about in the piece, you know, they've learned that rain water is bad. The problem for us is that we see water as our enemy. We have learned that water that floods is a problem. And we've learned that for the last 700 years. So it's really hard to change the way in which we see rainwater. But they really have to because that rainwater is an asset that has been wasted for so long.
南非会很乐意拥有像墨西哥城那样多的雨水。但由于我们故事中提到的洪水历史，你知道，他们已经学会了雨水是坏东西。对我们来说，问题在于我们将水视为敌人。我们已经学会了洪水是一个问题。而且在过去的700年里我们一直这样认为。所以改变我们看待雨水的方式真的很难。但他们必须改变，因为雨水是一种被浪费了太久的资产。
We spent literally hundreds of years focusing on get the rainwater out of the valley as fast as you can so that we don't flood out. And, you know, the consequence of doing that for so long has been like the desiccation of the watershed. So this is Enrique Lomnitz. And Enrique is the co-founder of an organization called Isla Urbana. It means like urban island in Spanish. And the whole goal of Isla Urbana is to try and take advantage of all that rain, to try to flip the equation on its head and say, let's turn this rain water into an asset. And to do this, what they do is they design and install rain water harvesting systems on people's homes. And Enrique says that this makes sense for a couple of different reasons. One, because it provides people with reliably clean water. And two, because it reduces the pressure on the groundwater aquifer.
我们花了整整几百年的时间专注于尽快将雨水排出山谷，以免被淹。而且，你知道，长期这样做的后果就是流域的干涸。这是恩里克·洛姆尼茨。恩里克是“Isla Urbana”组织的联合创始人。在西班牙语中意为“城市岛屿”。Isla Urbana的全部目标是尝试利用所有这些雨水，试图扭转局面，说：让我们把这些雨水变成一种资产。为了做到这一点，他们设计并安装了家庭雨水收集系统。恩里克说，这在几个不同的层面上是有意义的。第一，因为它为人们提供了可靠的清洁水。第二，因为它减轻了地下含水层的压力。
So, rainwater harvesting systems, like we use, they help you avoid pulling water out of the ground, and they help you avoid kind of putting water into the sewage system, and they help a family in parts of the city that are having big water problems. And Rique helped launch the organization in 2009 in a neighborhood that had particularly bad water problems. And RIKI helped launch the organization in 2009 in a neighborhood that had particularly bad water problems. Like people are starting to open their taps and have like brown water come out of the tap, no, or just not have any water coming out of the tap sometimes for weeks on end. So are there's birds on here and on the tape there?
所以，像我们使用的雨水收集系统，它们帮助你避免从地下抽水，也帮助你避免将水排入污水系统，它们帮助城市中面临严重水问题的家庭。恩里克在2009年帮助发起了这个组织，当时在一个水问题特别严重的社区。恩里克在2009年帮助发起了这个组织，当时在一个水问题特别严重的社区。就像人们开始打开水龙头，水龙头里流出棕色的水，或者有时连续几周根本没有水流出来。所以这里有鸟叫声吗？
Did you record that? Yeah, yeah, I saw it doing RIKI from some rural town that apparently is filled with parakeets. There's a lot of birds on the Skype tape. All right. Okay, there we go. But anyway, his organization is a lot of urban. They designed these systems for individual homes.
你录到了吗？是的，是的，我看到恩里克来自某个显然到处都是长尾小鹦鹉的城镇。Skype录音里有很多鸟叫声。好吧。好的，就这样。但无论如何，他的组织是Isla Urbana。他们为个人家庭设计这些系统。
And this system basically collects rainwater from the roof of the house, filters out all the kinds of impurities that you might have, and then stores it in a big tank for daily use. So in some ways it's a pretty simple sort of design intervention, but the thing that that makes it the work really challenging is that you can't just mass produce this system and ship it out. Every house is different. So every rainwater boosting system is like a custom install and every family has to be trained and taught how to use a rainwater harvesting system and what it's for and how to use it and how not to use it and what to be careful of. And so the work ends up being really social. You can't just drop the technology on people.
这个系统基本上从屋顶收集雨水，过滤掉你可能遇到的各种杂质，然后将其储存在一个大水箱中供日常使用。所以在某些方面，这是一种相当简单的设计干预，但让这项工作真正具有挑战性的是，你不能只是大规模生产这个系统并运出去。每栋房子都不同。所以每个雨水收集系统都是定制安装的，每个家庭都必须接受培训，教他们如何使用雨水收集系统，它的用途是什么，如何使用，如何不使用，以及要注意什么。所以这项工作最终变得非常社会化。你不能只是把技术扔给人们。
You have to cultivate relationships and get them on board. And so can you drink the water? Is it clean water? No, it's not clean enough to drink, but it is clean enough for just about every other household you use who could have. That makes up the vast majority of the water that a home uses. What is the scale that they're working on? How many of these water systems are they trying to get installed around the city?
你必须培养关系并让他们参与进来。那么你可以喝这些水吗？它是干净的水吗？不，它不够干净到可以饮用，但它足够干净，可以用于家庭使用的几乎所有其他用途。这构成了家庭用水的绝大部分。他们工作的规模有多大？他们正试图在城市周围安装多少这样的水系统？
Yeah, so at this point, they've built about 11,000 rainwater harvesting systems. So, you know, it's a lot, but it's not a lot in the grand scheme of things. And mostly they've been doing this on a fairly small scale and going kind of neighborhood to neighborhood, very grassroots approach. But things even in the last couple of years are really starting to scale up. And Mexico City just elected a new mayor. Her name is Claudia Scheinbaum, and she's a scientist who spent her whole, a scientist being elected mayor of cities. It's not a normal background for a political candidate
是的，到目前为止，他们已经建造了大约11,000个雨水收集系统。所以，你知道，这很多，但在宏观层面上并不算多。而且他们大多是在相当小的规模上进行，从一个社区到另一个社区，非常草根的方法。但即使在过去几年里，事情也真的开始扩大规模了。墨西哥城刚刚选出了一位新市长。她的名字叫克劳迪娅·辛鲍姆，她是一位科学家，她的一生……科学家被选为城市市长。这对于政治候选人来说不是正常的背景，
in any country really, but she spent her whole career studying environmental issues, water issues specifically. She's got an engineering background, so this is all really up her alley. And since her election, just know, just this past year, the government, the city government has started to work much more closely with this Lyrebana and they really want to push rainwater harvesting on a really large scale.
在任何国家都不是，但她整个职业生涯都在研究环境问题，特别是水问题。她有工程背景，所以这一切都非常符合她的专长。自她当选以来，就在过去的一年里，政府，市政府已经开始与Isla Urbana更紧密地合作，他们真的想在大规模上推动雨水收集。
The Mexico City government was like, dude, this is an important project and we need to do it huge. Knowing all of the parts of the city that don't have water. And we're installing, we're gonna be installing 10,000 rainwater harvesting systems there this year, and if all goes well, finance the installation of like 100,000 or more rainwater harvesting systems over the next two years. So it's definitely a large scale experiment at this point,
墨西哥城市政府当时的态度是：伙计，这是一个重要的项目，我们需要大规模地做。了解城市中所有没有水的地区。我们今年将在那里安装10,000个雨水收集系统，如果一切顺利，在未来两年内资助安装100,000个或更多的雨水收集系统。所以这在目前绝对是一个大规模的实验，
and it's kind of one of it kind in the world. Well, so they're like scaling up like 10 times, like for about 10,000 to 100,000, that's amazing. Yeah, it's really cool to see, but even Enrique isn't trying to argue that rainwater harvest thing is the solution. It's really gonna take a whole basket of different strategies to get Mexico City out of this mess.
而且在世界上也是独一无二的。好吧，所以他们正在扩大规模，大约10倍，从10,000到100,000，这太棒了。是的，看到这一点真的很酷，但即使是恩里克也没有试图争辩说雨水收集就是解决方案。要让墨西哥城摆脱这种困境，真的需要一整套不同的策略。
We're gonna get out of this situation by doing a whole bunch of things together, but that fundamentally just create balance between how much water we actually put just create balance between how much water we actually put into the ground and how much water we pull out of the ground. It's fundamental is that in its most basic essence. With that in mind, Loretta Castro-Vegada, the architect we heard from earlier, is focusing on designing parks and other public spaces that also function as water and infrastructure. So, you know, like a public sister
我们将通过共同做很多事情来摆脱这种局面，但从根本上讲，只是在我们要投入地下的水量和我们从地下抽取的水量之间建立平衡。它的基本本质就是这样。考虑到这一点，我们之前听到的建筑师洛雷塔·卡斯特罗·里维拉，正专注于设计公园和其他公共空间，这些空间同时也作为水利基础设施。所以，你知道，就像一个公共蓄水池，
and they can collect rain for a lot of different people or a public park that has a ground water infiltration component where you've actually got rain water flowing back to the aquifer. And so her goal is to create a whole network of green infrastructure so that when those rains come, the city can take that water in and make use of it. In a sense in which the city could really become a sponge. So when we have one of these rainstorms,
它们可以为许多不同的人收集雨水，或者一个具有地下水补给功能的公共公园，在那里你实际上有雨水流回含水层。所以她的目标是建立一个完整的绿色基础设施网络，这样当雨季来临时，城市可以吸收这些水并加以利用。从某种意义上说，这座城市真的可以变成一块海绵。所以当我们遇到这些暴雨时，
all these public spaces somehow are able to hold rain water and keep it there until the storm passes. You know, in that way, theoretically, a big rainstorm could be something that people are looking forward to and hoping for rather than something that they fear. Because it would both collect water that they need and also mitigate flooding because the water would be drained to the aquifer instead of being on the surface and trap their destroying things.
所有这些公共空间在某种程度上都能够容纳雨水，并将其留存到暴雨过后。你知道，从这个意义上说，理论上，一场大暴雨可能会成为人们期待和希望的事情，而不是他们恐惧的事情。因为它既能收集他们需要的水，又能减轻洪水，因为水会被排入含水层，而不是留在地表并造成破坏。
It's true. It's true. Yeah, if you can hold that water, you're also preventing that water from turning into dangerous runoff that causes problems. And, you know, I mean, you shouldn't go too far with that. Like, flooding requires its own, you know, in order to solve the flooding problem, there's other things that are needed. There are architects that are actually thinking about, you know, bringing back remnants of
确实如此。没错。是的，如果你能留住这些水，你也就防止了这些水变成造成问题的危险径流。而且，我的意思是，你不应该走得太远。比如，洪水需要它自己的，你知道，为了解决洪水问题，还需要其他东西。有些建筑师实际上正在考虑，你知道，带回
the old lake systems as ways to allow water to flood into these spaces that can hold and retain water and keep people safe. There's all kinds of things that architects and designers are thinking about. And engineers, too, the big problem is leaks. The whole water system is old and filled with leaks. Some people estimate they're losing as much as 40% of water in leaks. So, in terms of low hanging fruit, that's a great place to start. Also wastewater reuse.
旧湖泊系统的残余，作为让水流入这些空间的方式，这些空间可以容纳和保持水，并确保人们的安全。建筑师和设计师正在考虑各种各样的事情。工程师也是如此，最大的问题是泄漏。整个供水系统都很陈旧，充满了泄漏。有些人估计他们损失了高达40%的水。所以，就低垂的果实而言，这是一个很好的起点。还有废水再利用。
You know, there's so many different things that need to happen. And the red is point is basically like, we need all of it. There's not one. We're not waiting around for the best solution. We need, it's in all of the above strategy. Because what I see at this moment is that we have the enough infrastructure to keep the city safe for 30 years. So we can think on to a window of 30 years in which we have a very big opportunity of putting up
你知道，有太多不同的事情需要发生。重点基本上是，我们需要所有这些。没有一个。我们不是在等待最好的解决方案。我们需要的是一种“以上皆是”的策略。因为我此刻看到的是，我们有足够的基建来保障城市30年的安全。所以我们可以考虑30年的窗口期，在这期间我们有一个非常好的机会来实施
all these alternate water management strategies, right? Then we could really use this 30 years for our best benefit. And in 2050, not have this problem of we have no more water and the city disappears now because we also know from history that many cities disappeared because of lack of water right? Wow I mean it's kind of terrifying thought like a real existential crisis about the existence of an entire city because of water. Yeah and an absolutely massive city you know 22-23 million people it's really scary. But, you know, I mean, honestly, everyone that I talked to seemed a little more optimistic than I was expecting.
所有这些替代的水管理策略，对吧？那么我们真的可以利用这30年为我们带来最大的利益。到2050年，就不会出现我们没有水了，城市消失了的问题，因为我们也从历史上知道，许多城市因为缺水而消失了，对吧？哇，我的意思是，这是一种可怕的想法，关于整个城市因为水而存在的真正生存危机。是的，而且是一个绝对巨大的城市，你知道，2200到2300万人，这真的很可怕。但是，你知道，我的意思是，老实说，我交谈过的每个人似乎都比我预期的要乐观一些。
And I think that that optimism comes from the sense that the city really feels like it's undergoing a real shift right now in how it thinks about water and how it deals with water towards, you know, really embracing all the rain that flows into the basin. And the question is just like, can that shift happen fast enough? We can make another interview in 15 years and we'll see if it's working or not, right? Yeah, let's book her right now. Yeah, all right. Thanks so much. Thank you.
我认为这种乐观来自于一种感觉，即这座城市现在确实感觉正在经历一场真正的转变，关于它如何思考水以及如何处理水，朝着，你知道，真正拥抱流入盆地的所有雨水。问题只是，这种转变能发生得足够快吗？我们可以在15年后进行另一次采访，看看它是否有效，对吧？是的，我们现在就预定吧。好的，非常感谢。谢谢。
99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed in tech production by Shereef Yusuf, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trufflement, Terran Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. This episode was supported by the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation,
本周的《99% Invisible》由Emmett Fitzgerald制作，Shereef Yusuf进行混音和技术制作，音乐由Sean Riel创作。Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colstad是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑Delaney Hall、Avery Trufflement、Terran Mazza、Vivian Lee、Sophia Klatsker、Joe Rosenberg，以及我Roman Mars。本集由Alfred P. Sloan基金会支持，
enhancing public understanding and engagement with science and technology. More information on Sloan at Sloan.org. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Roe in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
旨在加强公众对科学技术的理解和参与。更多关于Sloan的信息请访问Sloan.org。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Roe制作。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me, at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the beautiful lava field that we call home is 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@我，@Roman Mars，或者@节目组99PI Org。我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。但我们称之为家的美丽熔岩地是99pi.org。PRX旗下的Radio Topia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。